On December 24th, 2025, Algeria's
parliament unanimously passed a law
declaring France's 132-year colonization
of the North African nation a crime. The
Algerians are further demanding a formal
apology and reparations from France.
Interestingly, this new law also
stipulates prison sentences for any
Algerian who speaks well of French
colonialism or makes quote any remarks
with colonial connotations. This is
what's known as selective outrage. Yes,
France colonized Algeria for over a
century, but it also brought to that
nation's Muslims what they did not have
before. Functional governance,
infrastructure, technology, medicine,
and in a word, progress. Hence why this
new law criminalizes speaking well, as
many especially older Algerians still
do, of the colonial era. Moreover,
France did give its former colony
priority in migration, allowing millions
of Algerians to relocate to France for a
better life as a form of compensation or
reparations. Now, ask yourself, what has
Algeria done to atone for the centuries
of crimes it committed against the
Europeans, including the French? For
over 300 years, from around the 16th to
the early 19th century, the Muslims of
North Africa, also known as Barbarie,
that is land of the barbarians, thrived
on enslaving Europeans. According to the
conservative estimate of American
professor Robert Davis, quote, "Between
1530 and 1780, there were almost
certainly a million and quite possibly
as many as a million and a quarter white
European Christians enslaved by the
Muslims of the Barbrey Coast." End
quote. Virtually no part of coastal
Europe was safe from these Muslim
pirates. From 1627 to 1633, Lundy, an
island off the west coast of Britain,
was actually occupied by them. From it
they pillaged England at will. In 1627
they raided Denmark and even far off
Iceland, hauling a total of some 800
slaves. In 1631, the fishing village of
Baltimore in Ireland was raided. And
according to an early source, quote, 237
persons, men, women, and children, even
those in the cradle, were seized and
taken to the miserable slave markets of
North Africa. The most notorious and
largest of which was centered in irony
of all ironies, Algeria.
Then there were the sadistic torments
Christian captives were subjected to.
Many, of course, were forced into hard
labor in quaries with barely any food or
water. Others were rowers on Ottoman
galleys, chained for hours, beaten by
their overseers, and worked to death.
Women and girls were, of course, sold
into concubinage, enduring sexual abuse,
as did not a few boys and even men. With
countless European women selling for the
price of an onion, little wonder by the
late 1700s, observers noted how, quote,
"The inhabitants of Alers have a rather
white complexion. Punishments for those
who resisted or in any way spoke
negatively of Islam, Muslims, and
especially Muhammad beggar description
and included being impaled alive and
roasted alive." Other European slaves
were quote thrown from the city walls
and caught upon large sharp hooks on
which they hang till they expire. After
a Muslim man tried to engage in
homosexual relations with his young male
European slave and the latter outraged
killed him, the hapless Christian was
quote dragged to the place of execution
over the rough and pointed stones,
subjected to the insults of an excited
and brutal crowd. On his arrival there,
each of the spectators seemed to take a
pleasure in assisting at the work. He
was crucified against the wall with four
large nails. A red hot iron was thrust
through his cheeks to prevent him from
speaking, and in this condition he was
slowly burnt to death with firebrands.
Such acts of cruelty were by no means
uncommon, says this early source. Nor
was America spared. In 1785, Muslim
pirates from Alers captured two American
vessels. Considering the horrific ways
Christian slaves were treated in
Barbary, tortured, pressured to convert,
and sodomized as described in the
writings I've been quoting from
missionaries and redeemers such as John
Fox, Father Dan, Father Jerome Morand,
Robert Playfair. If you have my book,
Sword and Scimitar, see pages 279 to
283, which have many of their quotes.
From here, one can understand why
Captain O'Brien, one of the enslaved
Americans, later wrote to Thomas
Jefferson, saying that, quote, "Our
sufferings are beyond our expression or
your conception." He was not
exaggerating. As ambassadors to France
and England, Jefferson and John Adams
met with one of Barbar's envoys to
Britain, one Abdul Rahman. In a March
28, 1786 letter to Congress, Jefferson
explained the source of Barbber's
hostility. Quote, "We took the liberty
to make some inquiries concerning the
grounds of their pretensions to make war
upon nations who had done them no
injury. And we observed that we
considered all mankind as our friends,
who had done us no wrong, nor had given
us any provocation." The ambassador
answered us that it was founded on the
laws of their prophet, that it was
written in their Quran, that all nations
who should not have acknowledged their
authority were sinners, that it was
their right and duty to make war upon
them wherever they could be found, and
to make slaves of all they could take as
prisoners, and that every Muslim who
should be slain in battle was sure to go
to paradise. And yet here is Algeria
today lecturing western people about
morality, branding France a criminal
colonizer and demanding reparations
because France colonized that is
civilized Algeria including by forcing
it to stop subsisting on slavery. The
irony is staggering. It's not just that
Muslims in general had a long history of
enslaving Europeans but that Algeria was
arguably the worst of all these Muslim
slavers of Europeans. At any given time
for three centuries, Alers held tens of
thousands of European slaves. Entire
coastal regions of France, Italy, and
Spain were repeatedly raided, leaving
devastation and destruction in their
wake. European captives, as we saw,
endured unspeakable horrors. Torture,
forced labor, sexual abuse, starvation,
and death. By the way, there's another
great irony here. France's entire
rationale for invading Algeria in the
first place was precisely to put an end
to its Muslim slave market which had for
centuries prayed on Europeans. At any
rate, and when it comes to reparations,
whatever you think of France's colonial
history in Algeria, it has at least and
as mentioned privileged its former
colony by allowing millions of Algerians
to move to and pursue a better life in
France. Meanwhile, what has Algeria done
to atone for the millions of Christians
it enslaved, tortured, and killed?
Nothing. Not a word of apology, not a
single dinar in reparations, not even
acknowledgement in its school textbooks.
Oh, and speaking of reparations, between
1795 and 1800, the United States was
forced to spend 16% of its annual
federal budget on ransom payments to
Alers in order to release some American
sailors and buy a few years of peace
before Alers became more demanding again
and the first Barbrey War broke out. So,
by Algeria's own logic, shouldn't it be
making reparation payments to the US? In
short, Algeria has just exposed itself
in front of the whole world as a
shameless hypocrite.
[Music]